the Joe Rogan experience if you had to
like if you were speaking in front of
Congress yeah and you were talking about
reparations what would you have to say
keep the conversation going open up the
conversation and let's get more Minds
involved don't shoot it down and Dems
must pay you know I got the hashtag go
and Dems must pay why Dems because it's
a great start number one so you know
when we had the debate with CJ Pearson
he said you know in his rant you know he
went off about God and he said if
anything the damage should pay is the
liberal rules because they had the KKK
they had they own slavery they ran a
slave trade Dada
so as like well if that's the case then
why don't we make them pay the other
thing is you know if you're conservative
and you know you're having this elect
election race or whatever why don't you
just take the wild card away from him
you know from the left and say well yeah
you know if there is a reparations
conversation you know that was the
Democrats I was the Dixiecrats that
installed Black Codes in South Carolina
they're the ones that that's an
interesting conversation right when you
say that yeah and like wait what yeah
actually the Democrats are responsible
yeah you had the thing called Black
Codes and if you were considered black
then you didn't have rights the funny
thing is you could be technically
African and be white white isn't a color
it's a status Elon Musk what do you mean
it's from Africa is he yep why I knew it
he's not in Africa well he was born in
Africa but he's not in Africa South
African but so so when we do his uh
23andme what is this probably a Dutch or
something all day it's actually
something right Europe okay but there is
white people that their lineage from
historically is from Africa sure well I
mean the Sephardic people that lived in
northern Africa right mm-hmm
yeah where it's considered more Middle
East right right right you can see some
of that absolutely but these people
aren't the African right people come
from Turkey right right well I'm from
Kiev Russia mm-hmm no that's where they
come from they they migrated into Africa
that's not what he from right there
bodies aren't even biologically
conducive to that environment you know
I'm not conducive to the New York
environment wife who is exactly where
why folks is running on the street when
shorts and I'm just like oh I need a
jacket but there's definitely a
biological difference data we got it
recognize for sure know where we came
from
yeah yeah yeah it's a lot to this
conversation there's a lot of this
conversation but it's so heavily
weighted people don't want to be
objective about it
[Applause]